why do we need cheap food we need cheap
food because wages are so low Raj Patel
is an academic author and activist he's
been called a rockstar in the food
justice movement and even a messiah so I
sat down with him at ut-austin
micro firm to get the skinny on the
global food system how is it that we can
have so many people who are starving and
so many people who are obese at the same
time well I mean the driver is always
the same it's poverty if you are
starving in the world today it's because
you don't have enough money to be able
to buy food and that's that's as true in
the United States as it is elsewhere so
in the United States we have 50 million
people who are food insecure who at some
point during the year don't have enough
money to be able to buy their next meal
and globally the reason we have around a
billion people who are malnourished the
reason that they are going hungry again
is because they are too poor to be able
to buy good food but if you are able to
buy food of some description and you are
and you still remain poor then the kinds
of options that are available
particularly in cities aren't very good
with the rise of industrial and
processed food there are far more easy
calories available and far less
nutritious good calories available and
good food available and that's one of
the reasons why we live in the world
that has a billion people who are
starving and nearly 2 billion people who
are now overweight when we're talking
about poverty is there a gender
component to it as it exists around the
world is there an inequality between men
and women right absolutely if you look
at the people who are going hungry in
the world today 60% of people going
hungry are women or girls and again it's
because money is power and in general
people who control money in households
tend to be men and that is true again in
the United States as it is elsewhere
it's about access to power and access to
money it's there a role that
corporations play here and so what is it
well I mean corporations would say
Americans have more food choice than
anyone else because of corporations in
America today and it's true there are so
many different shapes and cans and
flavors of zero calorie things and give
these soda corporations are very happy
to say look if you want no calories we
can give you no calories in so many
different forms
this is choice and freedom and we're not
forcing anyone to be able to
to be overweight at all we are totally
guiltless in all of it um and of course
that's a little disingenuous the reason
this is it's a bit strange for them to
say that is because these corporations
make most of their money by selling salt
fat and sugar precisely the kinds of
things that are responsible for driving
an epidemic of diabetes for example and
at the same time these corporations are
in the business of trying to get every
cent of subsidy they can out of the US
government so at the same time as being
able to produce cheap food they are
producing the kinds of food that are
going to be resulting in the sort of
epidemic of overweight and since what
extent should we be then fighting the
corporations and and and how um the
extent to which would be should be
fighting the corporations is all at an
time I mean if you look at the modern
food system the reason we have a food
system in which has very little
democracy and in which we're told that
cheap food is what we need to be fine
people the whole world wants cheap food
if we're if we're interested in a
different food system we need to be
thinking first of all of getting rid of
the corporations that peddle this cheap
food but also we need to be demanding
higher wages because it's no good saying
well you know you should eat organic and
you should eat local and you know
homegrown and fair trade when the prices
of all those things necessarily are much
higher
what should Americans know about the
food lobby in Washington eight out of
ten of the worst paid jobs in America
are in the food system in part that
because the National Restaurant
Association has done its level best to
keep wages lower and it's happened
because the National Restaurant
Association has been such an effective
Lobby there's an amazing amount of food
lobbying that goes on from the consumer
end all the way to lobbying for changes
in farm subsidies and all of this gets
in the way of having a kind of national
food policy in America that is going to
keep Americans healthy rather than
that's going to keep profit lines back